Dave Chappelle celebrated his 50th
birthday last week in front of a
sold-out crowd at Madison Square Garden
but the comedian was far from alone on
stage the guest list from that night
might be one of the craziest lineups in
MSG history including Shane Gillis Jeff
Ross Aziz Ansari Donnell Rawlings Chris
Rock and Pete Davidson to open the show
as well as musical acts like John Mayer
burnaboy and Travis Scott who just
released a song featuring Dave Chappelle
on his new album Utopia Cactus Jack
pulled up to MSG to celebrate Chappelle
turning 50 and led the audience in
singing happy birthday to the goat
birthday
the party continued the following night
at The Comedy Cellar where even more
stars showed up including Justin
Timberlake Chance the Rapper Andrew
Schultz and many more